نحنا من حمله مدارس التعاون مع وزاره
الصحه عم نطعم ضد الكوليرا ياللي هي ضد
الاسهال اوكي وهو ما في مشكله عليها من
عمر سنه
ابواب المناطق التي شهدت الاعداد الاكبر
الحمله الوطنيه
تحسنت التغذيه بالطاء الكهرباء كثير من
حطاب ضخ المياه اللي عندنا ان كان بالشمال
او غير مناطق هتصير تشتغل وكذلك محطات
تكرير الماء طبعا يعني نحنا ما في شكل انه
الجهود لاصلاح البنيه التحتيه هي هتاخذ
وقت ولذلك نحن اهميه حمله اللقاح اللي
عملها وتجهيز المستشفيات انه نحن نقدر نحد
منها الانتشار
الحمله في مرحلتها الاولى
لثلاثه اسابيع على ان تصل حوالي 70% من
القاتلين في المناطق الاكثر عرضه للواء
اللي وصلوا اليوم هن اول 600000 همم لقاح
جايه مليونين كمان من قبل منظمه الصحه
العالميه مليونين دوز اضافيات راح يجوا
باقسام 500 الف 600,000 وراء بعض
وانتباعان من هلا لاخر السنه وحتى لحظه
اعداده هذا التقرير فقط سجلت في لبنان 18
حاله وفاه منذ انتشار الكوليرا و500 و21
اصابه واكثر من ثلاثه الاف حاله مشتبه بها
والامال من حملات التوعيه والجهود الطبيه
في ان لا ترتفع هذه الارقام لا يكفي
التلقيح ضد الكوليرا للحد من انتشار
الوباء في الجهود ايضا منصبه على تامين
مياه نظيفه وشبكات صرف صحي ومياهرين
للمزروعات غير ملوثه وفي حال لم تعالج هذه
المشاكل فسيبقى لبنان بؤره لمختلف الاوبئه
والامراض من بحنين شمال لبنان ناهد يوسف
العربيه